here's the agenda for today as usual a
bunch of announcements in
red assignment 4 was graded there will
be
comments showing up online on stellar
soon on any of you didn't get a near
perfect score
on it and i'll also be going over a
little bit of it in
in a moment
and then once we do that we're going to
talk about navigation how we know where
we are and how to get from here to
someplace else which is much more
awesome than it sounds at first as you
will see
okay so quick uh review
um okay so what was the key point why
did i assign the hackspeed 2001 article
for you guys to read it it presents this
important challenge to the functional
specificity of the face area and the
place area what was that challenge
what was hacksby's key point
yes isabelle whether the um
va is just
attracts like it's just uh
has a preference for rick linear
that's what central standard for it's
not truly detecting whether something
yeah he wasn't worrying about
rectilinearity so much back then but his
point was that if you that we shouldn't
care just about the overall magnitude of
response of a region like okay it's nice
if the face area responds like this to
face isn't like that to objects
but even if it responds low and the same
to cars and chairs
it might still have information to
enable you to distinguish cars from
chairs if the pattern of response across
voxels in that region was stably
different for cars and chairs
okay that's really key we'll go over it
a few more points but that's that's
essential right a lot of the details
that i'm going to teach you that that go
by in class don't matter but i really
want you guys to understand in vpa and
that's the nub of it okay so the idea is
that selective his
his kind of um
claim is that selective regions like the
face area contain information about
non-preferred stimuli that is like
non-faces for the face area or
non-places for the place area
and because they contain information
those regions don't care only about
their preferred category so
why does can washer get off saying the
ffa is only about faces and the ppa is
only about places if we can see
information about other things in those
regions okay that's a really important
critique that's why we're spending time
on it okay okay
next what kind of empirical data
might
be an answer
to haxby's charge
i've presented at least three different
kinds of data that can address this and
say hey wait a minute you know you have
a point but
what kind of data could speak to that
and respond to to hacksby
we didn't actually talk about this
explicitly in class but think about it
here's the here's the claim he makes
what might we say right so that's that's
empirically true like you look in the
ffa even in my own data i can
distinguish
uh chairs from shoes a little teeny bit
in the ffa okay so that empirical claim
is true
why might it nonetheless
be the case
that the face area is really only about
face recognition what other data have
you heard
in here that might
make you think that yes ben
yes
sorry the
presence of low-level stimuli that are
generally in bases but can also
um sparsely adopt chairs and cars
[Music]
absolutely so yes so put another way
even if you had a perfect
coder for faces you know like take your
best deep net for face recognition vgg
face
it can distinguish chairs and shoes too
right the features that you use to
represent faces will slightly
discriminate between other non-face
objects so the fact that we can see that
information in itself isn't strong
evidence that that region isn't doing
selectively isn't selective for face
perception absolutely what else
yeah okay with the like transcranial
magnetic stimulation that when you
stimulate like the ffa you look at a
face that affects it but when you are
looking at other objects
exactly and so what does that tell you
about okay so there's pattern
information in there
about other things beyond faces
but
apparently it's not used right
now with every bit of evidence you can
always argue back people say well tms
those effects are tiny maybe there isn't
we didn't have power detected blah blah
blah blah but at least absolutely you're
right tms argues against that what else
or at least is a way to argue against it
and the picture paper that i assigned
and other papers that we've talked about
in here provide some evidence that
actually at least the occipital face
area really is only causally involved in
face perception even if there's
information in there about other things
okay
what else what other methods can address
this
yeah
simulation
even when you president
takes uh
exactly exactly so these are both causal
tests right okay there's information in
there but is it causally used in
behavior right tms suggests not the
little bit of
a direct
intracranial stimulation data that i
showed you also suggests the causal
effects when you stimulate that region
are specific to face perception again
suggesting that even if there's pattern
information in there it's not doing
anything important because we can mess
it up and nothing happens to the
perception of things that aren't faces
absolutely what else
we talked about it very briefly a few
weeks ago
yeah
it just completely makes a person
incapable of perceiving this that that
is like
yes but yes but the crucial way yes but
the crucial way
to address hacks be be would be what
further aspect of that yes
apparently and by the way we don't
remove the area in humans
but occasionally we find a human who had
a lesion there due to a stroke and then
we studied them so they're still able to
do other categories exactly
exactly so all three lines of evidence
and
suggest from studies of prosopagnosia
electrical stimulation directly on the
brain and tms all can provide evidence
to various degrees again one can quibble
about each of these particular studies
but all of those suggest that even
though there's information in the
pattern haxby's right there's
information in there about other things
that aren't faces the only causal
effects when you mess up with that
region are on faces not on other things
that suggests that pattern information
is what they sometimes say in
philosophical circles as epi phenomenal
that is it's just not related to
um to
behavior and and
perception makes sense okay
moving along
how can we then use haxby's method to
not just engage in this little fight
about the ffa and how specific it is
um but to ask whether to harness this
method and ask other interesting
questions
from functional mri data how can we use
it to find out for example does the
place area discriminate say beach scenes
from city scenes we want to know what's
represented in there how could we use
this method to find out
yes
because i did and like trying to decode
her and see if it could
[Music]
exactly
exactly so we talked about decoding
methods last time as a way to use
machine learning to look at the pattern
of response in a region of the brain
and train the decoder so it knows what
bc what the response looks like
during viewing of beach scenes train it
so it knows what the response in that
region looks like when you're looking at
city schemes and then take a new pattern
and say okay is this more like the beach
pattern or is it more like the city
pattern and that's how you could decode
from that region yes that doesn't tell
us right in the sense that it's
it's not telling the i mean we know that
the this residue of information
nevertheless and a discriminator can be
built on any region to figure out
anything
almost
so
we have a true nile list here
um no it's a good question
it's not the case
that you can discriminate anything based
on any region of the brain
so there are some constraints there's
some things you can find in some places
and other things you can find
in other places and they're not
uniformly distributed over the brain
however the fact we just the point i
just made about yes there's
discriminative information in the face
area about non-faces but maybe it's not
used
should raise a huge caveat about this
whole method how do we ever know we see
some discriminative information how do
we know whether it's actually used by
the brain part of the brain's own code
for information or just epiphenomenal
garbage that's a byproduct of something
else
it's a really important question about
all of pattern analysis
okay we do it anyway because we're
beggars we can't be choosers in terms of
methods with human cognitive
neuroscience and we want to know
desperately what's represented in each
region so we do this but whenever you
see these lovely i can decode x from y
things you should always be wondering
who knows if that fact that you the
scientist can decode it from that region
means the brain itself is reading that
information out of that region
big important question
okay
all right put another way um so jimmy
mentioned just decoding in general
that's absolutely right but to directly
harness the haxby version of this what
would we do first we would functionally
localize the ppa
but by scanning them looking at scenes
and objects find that region in each
subject
then we would collect the pattern of
response across voxels in the ppa
while subjects were looking at say beach
scenes and so if this is the ppa this is
the pattern of response across voxels in
that region when they're looking at
beach scenes fake data obviously just to
give you the idea
right so we would split the data in half
even runs odd runs that would be like
even runs then we get another pattern
for odd runs and then we get another
pattern for when they're looking at city
scenes with even runs and another
pattern when they're looking at city
scenes and odd runs okay
so then
once we have those four patterns what is
the key prediction
if uh using haxby's correlation method
what is the key prediction if the ppa
if pattern of response in the ppa can
discriminate beach scenes from city
scenes what should we see from these
patterns what's the key prediction
claire
key prediction you have these four
patterns
in the ppa and now you want to know is
there information in there
that enables you to discriminate beach
scenes from city scenes is that like
beach even in the beach odd or less than
the achievement city
exactly exactly right it's actually you
know it sounds all like complicated it's
easy to get confused but the nub of the
idea is really simple it just says look
the beach patterns are stable we do
beach a few times we get the same
pattern more or less
we do city we get a different pattern
and we keep doing city we get the same
pattern more or less and the beach
pattern and the city pattern are
different
so that's the nova the idea and so you
can implement it with decoding methods
or the hacks b versions just to ask
whether the correlation between
two beach patterns beach even beach odd
is more similar than the pattern between
one of the beaches and one of the cities
okay
just asking are they more are they
stably similar within a category and
stably different from another category
does that make sense okay
um boom this is just so it's just a
variant of this thing i showed you guys
before we just harness this to
to ask whether that region can
discriminate okay and i just said all of
this
okay if you still feel shaky on this
there's a few things you can do um a
version of my little lecture on on this
method is here at the on my website you
can look at that it's just like six
minutes and it's basically what i did
before but if you want to go over it
again there it is
you can reread the hacksby paper which i
know is not super easy but it's actually
nicely written and if you read it
carefully it explains the method pretty
clearly you can talk to me or a ta
and we'll get back to this question of
whether we should do a whole matlab
based problem set on this
all right
okay let's move on and talk about
navigation
okay this is a monarch butterfly
it weighs about half a gram
and yet
each fall
the monarch migrates over 2000 miles
from the usa in canada down to mexico
in fact it migrates
it fly a single monarch flies 50 miles
in a single day it's pretty amazing for
this tiny little beautiful delicate
thing
even more amazing it flies to a very
specific forest in mexico that's just a
few acres in size and it arrives at that
particular forest
now that's already amazing but here's
the part that is just totally
mind-blowing
and that is
and it flies back north in the spring
and that is that this whole cycle
takes four generations to complete
and that means that the monarch that
starts up in canada and flies down to
that forest in mexico one monarch does
that
is the great great grandkid
of his ancestor that last went on that
route
put that in your head and smoke it
that's pretty amazing
okay
all right
consider the female loggerhead turtle
she um hatches at a beach and goes out
in the sea
and swims around in the sea for 20 years
before she comes back 20 years later for
the first time to the beach that she
hatched at
okay
now it's pretty amazing but some mothers
miss by 20 miles they go to the wrong
island or the wrong beach on the same
island okay
and so
you might think okay it's pretty good
it's not amazing
but here's the thing
the wrong beach that those mothers go to
is the exactly right beach had the
earth's magnetic field not shifted
slightly over those 20 years
they're exactly precise
but they just don't compensate for the
shift in the earth's magnetic field
here's a bat
this bat
maintains its sense of direction
even while it flies 30 to 50 miles in a
single night in the dark
catching food
okay and it maintains its sense of
direction even though it's flying around
in all different orientations in three
dimensions
and even as it flips over and lands
to
perch on the surface of a cave
doesn't get confused by being upside
down
okay
this is cataglyphus the tunisian desert
ant these guys are amazing they crawl
around on the surface of the tunisian
desert where it's 140 degrees in the
daytime
they have to crawl around up there to
forage for food
and then because it's so damn hot as
soon as they find food they zoom back to
their nest and go down in the nest where
it's cooler
so here is a track of cataglyphus
starting at point a
and foraging he's meandering around
looking for food going along this whole
crazy path to point b
and then if he finds food at point b
boom
straight line back exactly to the nest
now we might ask how does cataglyphus
keep track because he's doing all this
stuff
of where his heading is back to his nest
okay
the first thing you might think of is
things like what it looks like maybe
their landmarks maybe their odors maybe
their odors
but no
he doesn't use any of those things and
we know that
because when scientists who have set up
this measurement device
capture cataglyphus after he goes out on
this tortuous path and finds the feeding
station they capture him and move them
across the desert on which they've drawn
all these grid lines for the convenience
of their experiment and they release him
here and what does cataglyphus do
he goes on the exactly correct vector
no landmarks no relevant odors
and yet he's obviously encoded the exact
vector of how to get home
think about what that entails and what's
involved
okay the same vector with respect to
north with respect to this yes yes well
with respect to like absolute
um external direction absolutely
okay
so that's what i just said
so these feats of animal navigation
uh are amazing
um and animals have evolved ways to
solve all these problems unique to their
environment
they've evolved these
abilities because they really have to be
able to find food
and mates
and shelter
and this is not just esoterica in the
natural world
mit students too need to be able to find
food
and mates
and shelter
so
what is navigation anyway uh and what
does it entail
uh well i'll argue over the next two
lectures that there are two fundamental
questions that organisms need to solve
to be able to navigate first one is
where am i
and the second one is how do i get from
here to there a to b wherever there is
that you need to get
okay so we'll unpack this or many
different facets of each
but so for example
if you see this image
you immediately know
where you are
and you also know
where to go if for example it starts
raining
you might rush into lobby 7.
or if you're hungry you might turn
around and go back to the student center
right
same deal here if you see this
then you know where you are and where
you would go to get to various things
okay now these judgments rely on the
specific knowledge you you guys have of
those particular places you recognize
that exact place and you know
you have some kind of map in your head
that we'll talk more about in a moment
that tells you where everything else is
with respect to it
but even if you're in a place you don't
know at all
you can still extract some information
so suppose you miraculously found
yourself boom here
i wouldn't mind actually but that's not
in the cards for a while
um so you're here
even if you've just hiked around the
corner if you've never seen this place
before
you have some kind of idea what sort of
place this is where would you pitch your
tent
you know where might you try to go to
get out of this valley if it was me i
wouldn't i have friends who would go
straight up there and try to drag me
along complaining if it was me i'd
rather look for some other route
but you can tell all of that just by
looking at this image
okay okay where you can go from there
not just what kind of a place it is but
what are the possible routes you might
take
okay
so these fundamental problems that we
solve in navigation of knowing where am
i and how do i get from here to there
include multiple components in terms of
where am i the first the first piece is
recognizing a specific place you know
okay
so you might open your eyes and say okay
this is my living room i know this
particular place
okay
but as i just pointed out even if the
place is unfamiliar
we can get a sense of what kind of place
this is right am i in an urban
environment a natural environment a
living room a bathroom where am
i a third aspect of where am i a third
way that we might answer that question
is something about the geometry of the
environment we're in
so try this right now close your eyes
okay now think about how far the wall is
in front of you don't open your eyes
just think about how far away it is how
far away the left wall is and the right
wall is and how about the wall behind
you don't open your eyes how far back is
the wall behind you from where you are
right now
okay you can open your eyes it's not
rocket science i just wanted you to
intuit that even though you're
presumably riveted by this lecture and
thinking only about navigation you sort
of have a kind of situational awareness
of the spatial layout of the space
you're in
so
you might have a sense of okay i'm in a
space like this and i'm over here in it
right
and we'll talk more about that exact
kind of awareness of your position
relative to the spatial layout of your
immediate environment it's something
that's very important in navigation
and another part of that is you might
think how would i get out of here if i'm
seriously bored by the lecture or for
any other reason i urgently need to get
out of here you probably know exactly
where the doors are in this space it's
just part of those one of those things
that we
keep track of okay
okay so those are aspects of where am i
in this place
what are the things we need to know to
know how we would get from here to
someplace else
okay well the simplest way to navigate
to another location another goal is
called beaconing and this is the case
where you can directly see or hear your
target location so you're sailing in the
fog you can't see a damn thing but you
hear the fog horn over there and you
know you're sailing to that point so you
just go toward the sound
nice and simple you don't need any
broader map of anything else you just
hear it and head toward it
or
if you see this
and your goal is to get to the green
building
well you know there's a green building
and you just head that way now you're
gonna have to like go around a little
bit to get around those obstacles but
you know where to head because you can
see your target directly okay these are
cases where you don't need a broader
long-term knowledge of the whole
environment if you can see your target
you just go straight for it okay so
that's beaconing
simplest kind of a to b
um and it requires no mental map no kind
of internal model of the whole world
you're navigating in
but if you can't see the place you want
to go
then you need some kind of mental map of
the world so what do we mean by a mental
map of the world
well this idea was first articulated in
a classic experiment way back in the
1940s
so this was actually one of the original
experiments that launched the cognitive
revolution when we emerged from the the
scourge of behaviorism uh to realize it
was actually okay and indeed of the
essence to talk about what's going on in
the mind
and a really influential study that
launched the cognitive revolution
by tolman
was done on rats and it went like this
he trained rats he put them down in this
area and they had to learn that there
would be full
food out there at the goal and so they
just have to make the series of left and
right turns to find the food okay so you
train them on that for a while until
they're really good at it
and then you put the rats in this
environment
okay
now
the environment is similar except
there's multiple paths
one that seems analogous to the old
route
so what do the rats do in this situation
they run down here
they run into a wall and they realize
okay that's not going to work okay
nothing no surprises yet
but then the rats immediately come back
out and they go straight out that way
what does that tell you
what do they learn
did they learn a series of like go
straight and then left and then right
and then right and then go for a long
ways
no that wouldn't work over here
they learned something much more
interesting even though they were only
being trained on this task here they
learned some much more interesting thing
about the kind of vector average of all
of those turns
everybody get this it's really simple
but really deep
okay so from this tolman and others
started talking about cognitive maps
whatever it is you have to have learned
in a situation like this so you can
abstract the general direction
okay we don't just learn specific roots
as a series of
stimulus and responses okay so there
must be some kind of map in your head to
be able to do this
and rats have that
and so do you
so let's consider this question right
now where am i where are
you to answer that question to yourself
there's something like this in your head
and it probably doesn't look exactly
like that in your head but there's some
version of this information
that's in your head
that you're using when you answer the
question of where you are
okay
so
um and you have some way to say in that
map of the world i know not just what
the mit campus looks like and how it's
arranged but i know where i am in it
okay
now if you want to know how to get
somewhere else like suppose you're
hungry and you want to go over to the
stata cafeteria over there
what else do you need to know besides
knowledge of the map of your environment
and where you are in it what else do you
need to know
you know
you have this map you know where you are
and you know where your goal is now you
have to plan how to get over there what
else do you need to know
yeah you have to know which parts are
like paths and which parts are buildings
yes exactly where can you go in there
actually where can you physically get
through like actually our vector is
right over there but you can't go that
way because you can't go through that
glass even though you can see through it
right so knowledge of physical barriers
and what what's an actual path and what
isn't is crucial what else do you need
to know
suppose we had a robot in this room
sitting
right here facing the front of room like
you guys and we're programming the robot
on how to get over there what are other
things we'd have to tell that robot to
get it to plan
how to get over to the stata cafeteria
yeah things to watch out for like cars
and traffic absolutely we'd have to know
about obstacles like moving obstacles
not just fixed ones absolutely what else
yeah an issue or your addition yes he
has to know which way he's headed
right you're going to give this robot
instructions on which way to go it
matters a whole lot if the robot is
starting like this
or starting like that the instructions
are different in the two cases and
likewise for you guys to plan a route
you need to know which way you're
heading
okay
if you guys ever been in in manhattan
and you come up from the subway and you
see the streets going like this and you
know it's north south and you don't know
if you're heading south or north right
really common thing okay you need to
it's not enough to know i'm at the
junction of 5th and 22nd you need to
know am i facing south or north
otherwise you can't figure out which way
to go
that's called heading direction okay
um
okay we just did all that okay you need
to know your current heading
okay you also need to know the direction
of your goal in order to plan a route to
it
okay so in this kind of taxonomy of all
the things you need to know to navigate
uh we've just added that if you're gonna
navigate in your known environment you
need to know where not just where you
are in it
but which way you are facing in that
mental map
okay and we also talked about this
business of what routes are possible
from here how do we move around
obstacles
uh where are the doors uh where the
hazards like cars
etc a final thing you need to know
is that even if you have a good system
for all of these other bits it's still
possible to get lost in all kinds of
ways you lose track you get confused you
get lost
so we also need a way to reorient
ourselves when we're lost and we'll talk
a lot about that in the next lecture
okay so this is just common sense we're
doing a kind of low-tech version of mar
computational theory for navigation like
what are the things that we would need
to know or that a robot would need to
know to be able to navigate
okay just thinking about the nature of
the problem
all right
so that's what we need uh what's the
neural basis of all of this
all right
so i'm going to start right in with the
parahippocampal place area not to imply
it is the total neural neural basis of
this whole thing it's just one little
piece of a much bigger puzzle but we'll
start in there because it's nice and
concrete okay
all right so this story starts oh god
about 20 years ago uh i think i
mentioned some of this in the first
class when i talked about the story of
bob and i talked about russell epstein
who was in my postdoc
and it was doing nice behavioral
experiments and thought it was trashy
and cheap to mess around with brain
imaging and he was going to have none of
it until i said russell just do one
experiment scan subject looking at
scenes i know it's kind of stupid but
just do it then you'll have a slide for
your job talk
and he scans subjects looking at scenes
and looking at objects and here is one
of those early subjects probably me i
don't remember
with a bunch of vertical slices through
the brain near the back of the brain
down there moving forward as we go up to
here everybody oriented
okay
so sorry it's not showing up very well
in this lighting but there's a little
bilateral region right in the middle
there that shows a stronger response
when people look at pictures of scenes
than when they look at pictures of
objects
okay
so
we didn't we hadn't predicted this yeah
yeah yeah pink yeah pink is yeah all the
colors are um there's significance maps
or p levels right so pink is higher than
blue but you know blue is borderline
significant
okay
so this was kind of dopey we didn't
actually predict it for any deep reason
we hadn't been thinking about theories
of navigation or anything like that it
was just one of those dumb experiments
where we found something and we followed
the data so we found this and it's like
okay let's try some other subjects
so here are the first nine subjects we
scanned every single subject had that
kind of signature response in exactly
the same place
okay in a part of the brain called
parahippocampal cortex
okay so this is very systematic and
there's lots of ways to make progress in
science one way is to have a big theory
and use it to motivate
brilliant elegantly designed experiments
and another is you just see something
salient and robust that you didn't
predict and you follow your nose and try
to figure it out so that's what we did
in this case it's like okay what the
hell is that
all right
so um
if you think about we eventually called
it the para campbell place area after a
little more work
if you think about what we have so far
we've scanned people looking at pictures
like this and pictures like that and
what we've shown is that little patch of
brain responds a bunch more to these
than those
so my first question is is that a
minimal pair
talia's had a minimal pair sorry i'm
like
boys
sorry simple simple simple we're
contrasting this with that
um can you remind me what i'm going to
do okay minimal pair is this thing we
aspire towards in experimental design
where we have two conditions that are
identical except for one little thing
we're manipulating
i
don't i don't really think it's a
minimal pair but i'm not really sure
like
well i even told you what we were
designing to manipulate but
there seems to be like too many
differences between the living room and
like
it's ludicrous right i mean it's a
million differences here right so we
don't know that we have anything yet
there's all kinds of uninteresting
accounts of the systematic activation in
that part of the brain right so just to
list a few that you've probably already
noticed
these things have rich high level
meaning and complexity right so you
could think about living rooms or where
you might sit or you know somebody's
aesthetic
you know home design or you know god
there's all kinds of stuff to think
about there
much more than just okay it's a blender
right so there's just just complexity in
every possible way
there are also
lots of objects present here
and only a single object over there so
maybe that region it just represents
objects and if you have more objects you
get a higher signal right
there's another possibility
and that is that these images depict
spatial layout and that one does not
okay so you have some sense of the walls
and the floor and like the layout of the
local environment here that you don't
have over there
all right and we could probably list a
million other things okay that's a very
very sloppy contrast
okay so how are we going to ask which of
these things might be driving the
response of that region
well
a natural thing to do is just
deconstruct the stimuli
so here's what we did uh this is
actually way back 20 years ago there
were better methods at the time but i
didn't know them so i actually drove
around cambridge photographs my friends
apartments left the camera on the same
tripod moved all the furniture out of
the way and photographed the space again
i know
and then these we probably cut out with
some
horrific version of adobe photoshop that
existed 20 years ago
anyway we deconstructed the scenes into
their component objects and the bare
spatial layout
okay everybody get the logic here just
to try to make a big cut in this
hypothesis space of what might be
driving that region
okay
so what do we predict that the ppa will
resp how how strongly will it respond
um
oops
how strongly will it respond if these
two things are true if it's a complexity
or multiplicity of objects that's
driving it what do you predict we will
see over there we already know you get a
high response here what do we get over
there
yeah probably
yeah we'll respond more to this than
that
right it's really simple-minded right
if ins if instead it responds more to
the spatial layout
what do we predict
the
is
yeah
and that seems like a weird hypothesis
because these are really boring there's
kind of nothing going on here and
there's just lots of stuff going on here
i mean it's not riveting but it's a
whole much
whole lot more interesting to look at
these than those believe me i got
scanned for hours and hours looking at
these things and whenever the empty
rooms came on i was like oh my god i'm
just so bored right there's just nothing
here whereas here at least there's stuff
right
but that's not what the ppa thinks
what the pva does oops
oops we just did the localizer okay
it responds like this this is percent
signal change a measure of magnitude of
response to the full scenes
way down less than half the response to
all those objects and almost the same
response as the original scene
when all you have is a bare spatial
layout
pretty surprising isn't it
we were blown away we're like what what
but can you see how even this really
simple-minded experiment enables us to
just pretty much rule out that whole
space of hypotheses it's not about the
richness or interest or multiplicity of
objects
it's something much more like spatial
layout because that's kind of all there
is in those empty rooms
i mean it could be something like you
know the texture of wood floors or
something weird like that
but one's first guess is it's something
about spatial layout does this make
sense it's just a way to take a
a big sloppy contrast and try to
formulate initial hypotheses and knock
out a whole big space of hypotheses yes
is it alana yeah yeah
i'm sorry i might have missed your
original design
looking at the empty room
ah good question i skipped over all of
that
uh we didn't
we did yes that's true we did mush them
all together and one could worry about
that
that when you see this you remember that
that's a version of this
right
absolutely
absolutely
um
and so maybe yes
um nonetheless if what you were doing
that's absolutely true but if what you
were doing here
is kind of mentally recalling this
right then why couldn't you also do that
here
maybe you could
you might argue that this is more
evocative of that than this is but it's
also got lots of relevant information
okay yeah jimmy you
guys the furniture do you guys try
placing them in the same exact position
as the scene and seeing if that we did
both versions for exactly the reasons
you guys are pointing out uh and it
didn't make a difference
yeah
yeah uh sorry coolly uh maybe did you
turn for if the if they were just like
responding to that there's like
more
stuff
like in the empty room
there's more background but there's did
more background totally you're
absolutely right this has taken us
pretty far but it's still pretty sloppy
this stuff goes all the way out to the
edge of the frame and here there's lots
of empty space is that what you're
getting at
absolutely i took out those slides
because i felt i didn't want to spend
the entire lecture doing millions of
control conditions on the ppa i thought
you'd get bored but actually another
version
that we did was we then
took all of these conditions and we
chopped them into little bits and
rearranged the bits
so that you have much more coverage of
stuff when in the chopped up scenes than
the chopped up
uh objects
and it in the chopped up versions it
doesn't respond differently at all so
it's not the amount of total spatial
coverage it's the actual something more
like the depiction of space
was there a question over there yeah i
was wondering if there would be any
difference between shooting images as 2d
for the 3d scene and actually being
there to see the treatment
totally totally it's a real challenge
with navigation navigation is you know
very much about being there and moving
around in the space
and this is just a pretty rudimentary
thing where you're lying in the scanner
and these images are just flashing
flashing on and you're doing some simple
tasks like pressing a button when
consecutive images are identical it's
not like moving around in the real world
you don't think you're actually there
but here's where video games and vr come
in
because actually you know they produce a
pretty powerful simulation of knowing
your environment feeling you're in a
place in it and so lots of studies have
used those methods to
give something closer to the actual
experience of navigation
okay
um
so
so where are we so far we've said the
ppa seems to be involved in recognizing
a particular scene so it so this just
says it responds to scenes and something
about spatial layout maybe
does it care
about that particular scene
or something do you have to recognize
that particular scene to be able to use
the information
now our subjects mostly didn't know
those particular scenes but we wanted to
do a tighter contrast asking if
knowledge of the particular scene
matters
so what we did was we took a bunch of
pictures around the mit campus and we
took a bunch of pictures around the
tufts campus and we scanned mit students
looking at mit pictures versus tufts
pictures
and then what else do we do
yeah why
oh just to make sure that uh it's not
all about the weird architecture
exactly exactly so this is called
counter yes who's weird architecture i
think ours is weirder um
so it's not just about the particular
scenes or the particular subjects so
everybody get how with that
counterbalance design you can really
pull out the essence of familiarity
itself unconfounded from the particular
images
okay so when we did that
we found a very similar response
magnitude in the ppa for the
tough students and for the familiar and
unfamiliar scenes okay
really really didn't make much
difference
yeah
uh taking a step back so we started with
the wrong question of navigation yeah
and it involving all these different
components
uh i just want the place where this
we're getting there we're getting there
there won't be like a perfect answer
we're not going to end up with that
slide with the exact brain region of
each of those things uh we'll get some
gisty vague senses of what this is
yeah
okay so this tells us it's not about
it
it's whatever you do whatever the ppa is
responding to in a scene it's not
something that hinges on knowing that
exact scene so it can't be something
like okay if i was here and i wanted to
get coffee what would my route from this
location be given my knowledge of the
environment because otherwise we
wouldn't get this result so whatever it
is it's something more immediate and
perceptual to do with just seeing this
place
okay
all right
all right so where are we
we've said that there's this region that
responds more to scenes and objects
that when all the objects are removed
from the scenes the response you know
barely drops okay
and its response is pretty much the same
for familiar and unfamiliar scenes
so all of that suggests that it's
involved in something like perceiving
the shape of space around you
it doesn't nail it yet but it
kind of pushes you towards that
hypothesis yeah was there a question
here a second ago oh no okay
experiment no
is it activating you look at it back
oh great question uh not very much
okay
um
yeah if you take pictures of places from
above versus this kind of view you get a
response in this kind of view but not
above
yeah
very telling yeah
okay so i'm going to skip we're not
going to do like you know the 30 other
experiments we're going to skip to the
general picture that here's the ppa and
four subjects in this very stereotype
location and here are some of the many
conditions we've tested it's not just
you know abstract maps like this they
don't produce a strong response oh this
is an answer to cooley's question way
back here's the scrambled up scene much
lower response so it's not just coverage
of visual junk right
and
it responds pretty strongly to scenes
made out of legos compared to objects
made out of legos and various other
silly things
okay
so all of that seems to suggest that
it's processing something like the shape
or geometry of space around you visible
space in your immediate environment
okay
nonetheless
there's always push back
and there's push back on multiple fronts
and there should be that's proper
science
so one of the lines of pushback
was this paper by nasser at all
that i didn't assign i signed you the
response to it anyway what nostradal did
was scan people looking at
rectilinear things like cubes and
pyramids versus curvilinear roundy
things like cones and spheres
and what they showed is that ppa
responds more to the rectilinear than
the curvilinear shapes
okay
okay that's the first thing
and so then they argue that
in general scenes have more rectilinear
structure than curvilinear structure and
they did a bunch of math to make that
case
and so
they they argue
that maybe the apparent scene
selectivity of the ppa is due to a what
of scenes with rectilinearity
yeah
yes exactly a confound this is exactly
what a confound is something else that
co-varies with the manipulation you care
about that gives you an alternative
account namely okay it's not seeing
selectivity it's just rectilinearity i
mean that might be interesting to other
people but it would make it not very
relevant to navigation and much less
interesting to me at least right okay
so that's an important criticism
and so then the brian at all paper that
you guys read starts from there and says
okay let's take that seriously let's
find out
and so
um
you guys should have read all of this
but just to remind you they have a nice
little two by two design remember we
talked about two by two designs where
they manipulate whether the image has a
lot of rectilinear structure or less
rectilinear structure and whether the
image is a place or a face
okay um
and what they find in the ppa is the
same response to these
and it's higher to the scenes than the
faces
uh and rectilinearity didn't matter
for the scenes okay so evidently even
though it does matter with these
abstract shapes in actual scenes it
doesn't seem and faces it doesn't seem
to be doing much it's not accounting for
this difference
okay everybody get that
um
okay let's talk about this graph
are there main effects or interactions
here and what are those main effects or
interactions
yes fully there's immediate scenes yeah
of category scene versus face yeah
anything else
that was the first thing
in
oh
wait this here these are scenes and
those are phases
okay and i'm sorry and this is the code
here these are rectilinear versus
curvilinear
just one main effect or is there an
interaction or another main effect
no just one main effect okay
right these guys are higher than those
guys that's it
okay so that just tells you there's
nothing else going on in these data
other than seeing selectivity
okay rectilinearity doesn't interact
with or modify scene selectivity and it
doesn't have a separate effect
okay
nonetheless
as we've been arguing with all the whole
hacks be rigmarole does the fact that
there's no
main effect of rectilinearity in here
mean that the ppa doesn't have
information about rectilinearity
no josh why
i mean there's still a tiny amount that
could that could be enough
this is not the right experiment that's
right this is a big well it's a right
experiment but not the right analysis
right it's the big average responses are
the same but maybe the patterns are
different okay that wouldn't directly
engage with us but we want to know is
there information in there about
rectilinearity
okay
so how would we find out
so this was your assignment and i think
most people got it right but in case
anybody missed it
we were zooming in on these this figure
four here so again this is just the same
basic design of experiment two
and now let's consider what's going on
here so you guys read the paper and you
understood what was going on here what's
represented in that cell right there
what is the point of this diagram what
are they doing here and what does that
cell mean in that matrix
you can't understand the paper without
knowing that
is it ali
no sorry
what's your name
sharon i've only asked you like six
times yeah go ahead
so
they want to see whether
the
activation patterns can better
discriminate between
rectilinearity of the same category of
things or between categories of things
with the same rectilinearity so they um
the first thing i said is
to the
uh
left and the second one is the right
and they
sorry wait here and here no the right
side yeah so this part that part is
discriminating between um
vertical linearity and that side is
distributing between categories
and they take the differences of
well not the difference if they take
the
how well it can distinguish between each
of those categories and plug them down
there
right okay
that's exactly right so this is how well
it can discriminate plotted down here
but based on an analysis that follows
this scheme
so what does that cell in there
represent
that dark green cell what do they
what is the number that's going to be
calculated from the data corresponding
to that cell
similarities of uh saying that
continuity
exactly exactly so just as if you want
to distinguish chairs from cars or
something else if you want to know is
there information about rectilinearity
in there
you take these two cases which are the
same in rectilinearity both high
rectilinear both low rectilinear
for run one and run two and that's the
correlation between run and one 2 for
those cells
that's the within rectilinearity case
right and if there's information about
rectilinearity the prediction is those
within correlations are higher than the
between correlations
just as we argued a bit back with you
know beaches and cities and everything
else okay same argument this is just
presenting the data in terms of run one
and run two and which cells do we grab
to do this computation
okay
so
um so each of the cells in there for
each of the cells we're going to
calculate an r value of how similar
those patterns are
okay
pattern and
you know a pattern for rectilinear
scenes in run and run two a pattern for
rectilinear scenes in run one this cell
is the correlation between those two
patterns how stable is that pattern
across repeated measures
okay
all right so that's what that r value is
the two darker blue scare
squares here
are the r values
for stimuli that differ in
rectilinearity
and remember that the essence of the hex
b style pattern analysis
is to
see if the within correlations are
higher than the between correlations
in this case the within correlations are
within rectilinearity versus between
rectilinearity
okay
all right
and so then they calculate all those
correlation differences and they plot
them as discriminate discrimination
abilities
and so
what this is showing us here is that
actually the ppa doesn't have any
information in its pattern of response
about the rectilinearity of the scene
however if we take the same data
and now choose within category versus
between category
ignoring rectilinearity and we get the
same kind of um
selectivity
correlation difference within versus
between for category there's heaps of
information about category
does that make sense
okay again if you're fuzzy about this
look back on that slide i have lots of
suggestions for how to unfuzzy yourself
on it okay
all right so
into room summary pba responds more to
scenes and objects
it seems to like spatial layout in
particular it does respond more to boxes
and circles but that rectilinearity bias
can't account for scene selectivity
that's all very nice
but what is a whole other kind of
fundamental question we haven't yet
asked about the ppa
so we've been messing around with
functional mri measuring magnitudes of
response trying to test these kind of
vague
uh
you know general hypotheses about what
it might be responding to yes
yes what what particular causation
i guess like how it's in scenes
like how
the pva liquid will work place in person
exactly exactly again we can test the
causal role of a stimulus on the ppa all
of the stuff i talked about did that
manipulate the stimulus find different
ppa responses but what we haven't done
yet is ask
what is a relation the causal
relationship if any between activity in
the ppa and perception of scenes or
navigation okay
so so far this is all just suggestive we
have no causal evidence for its role in
navigation
right or perception
all right so let's get some
i'll show you a few examples
um so one as you guys have learned by
now is these rare cases where there's
direct electrical stimulation of a
region and there's one patient in whom
this is reported this patient again is
being mapped out before neurosurgery
there's
they did functional mri in the patient
first this is his functional mri
response to i think houses versus
objects houses are not as strong
an activator as scenes for the ppa but
they're pretty good ppa responds much
more to houses than other objects and so
that's a nice activation map showing the
ppa and those little circles are where
the electrodes are little black circles
okay
so um so they know they're in the ppa
because they did functional mri first to
localize that region now those
electrodes are sitting there
and so first thing we do is record or
the first thing they did is record
responses they flash up a bunch of
different kind of images and they
measure the response in those electrodes
and so what you see is in those
electrodes right over there one two
three that correspond to the ppa
you see a higher response to house
images than to any of the other images
and you see the time course here over a
few seconds
okay everybody clear this is not causal
evidence yet it's just amazing direct
intracranial recordings from the ppa
i think the only time this was ever done
because it's pretty rare to have the
electrodes right there in a patient
who's willing to look at your silly
pictures and all of that right
okay
but now
what happens when they stimulate there
okay so let's look at what happens when
they stimulate
um on these sites um
four and three that are off to the side
of the scene selectivity and this is
just a dialogue we don't have a video
unfortunately the videos are more fun
but it's just a dialogue between the
neurologist and the patient
and the neurologist electrically
stimulates that region
and
and says did you see anything there
patient says i don't know i started
feeling something i don't know it's
probably just me oh no it's not you
and then they stimulate again anything
there no anything here no okay so that's
right next to the side of the scene
selective electrodes right next door a
few millimeters away
then they move uh their stimulator over
here they don't move anything they just
control where they're going to stimulate
patient of course has no idea
neurologist says anything here do you
see anything
feel anything
patient says yeah i feel like he looks
perplexed
puts hand to forehead
i feel like i saw like
some other site we were at the train
station
neurologist cleverly says so it feels
like you're at a train station
patient says yeah
outside the train station neurologist
let me know if you get any sensation
like that again
it stimulates do you feel anything here
no
um
and he does it again do you see the um
do you see the the train station or did
it oh did you see the train station or
did it feel like you were at the train
station
patient i saw it
right these are very sparse precious
data but that's so telling it's not that
he knew he was at the train station
abstractly he saw it okay
so then they stimulate again right on
those
scene selective regions the patient says
again i saw almost like i don't know
like i saw it was very brief neurologist
says i'm going to show it to you one
more time really what he means is i'm
going to stimulate you in the same place
one more time see if you can describe it
any further um
i'm going to give you one last time what
do you think
i don't really know what to make of it
but i saw like another staircase
the rest i couldn't make out
but i saw a closet space but not this
one he points to a closet door in the
room
that one was stuffed and it was blue
have you seen it before it's a
neurologist have you seen it before at
some point in your life you think yeah i
mean when i saw the train station
train station you've been at yeah et
cetera et cetera
so
it's not a lot of data but it's very
compelling right what is the patient
describing
places that he's in that he sees
and then he describes this closet space
and its colors interestingly color
regions are right next to scene region
so that's kind of cool too
right
so
it's causal evidence it's sparse ideally
we'd like more in science but
it's pretty cool
yeah and all this far the patient is
just staring at a bank
you know i actually forget in the paper
i've got to go look that up i forget
exactly what the patient was doing
whether i think he's just in the room
looking out
usually they don't control it that much
because it's done kind of for clinical
reasons and the patient is in their
hospital bed and they're just
stimulating so he's probably just
looking out at the space he's in in fact
he must have been because at one point
he says a closet not like that one over
there so if he was staring at a blank
thing he was also
looking out at his room
okay
so
yeah so
this may be a little bit off topic you
said the region of color perception is
very close to this
is there any relationship between like
functional proximity and
that's a great question nobody in the
field has an answer to this people often
make hay about the proximity of two
regions like oh there's some deep link
because this thing is next to that thing
uh you know the body selective region is
right next to and in fact slightly
overlapping with uh area mt that
responds to motion it's like oh bodies
you know faces move and cars move too so
you know like i don't know it's
tantalizing it feels like it ought to
mean something and people often talk
about you know talk as if it does and
maybe it does but nobody's really put
their finger on what exactly it would
mean
but it's useful right so when when rosa
lay for souza who you met in the color
demo
and i showed that in
in humans you get face color and place
regions right next to each other in that
order that was really cool because rosa
had previously shown that in monkeys
in the monkey brain it goes face color
place in exactly the same order
and so we thought okay that's really
interesting that suggests common
inheritance because that's so weird and
arbitrary why would it be the same so it
can be useful in ways like that
at least
okay
so we just went through all of this so
how does this go beyond what we knew
from functional mri
i'm insulting your intelligence you know
the answer to this it goes beyond it
because it tells you it implies that
there's a causal role of that region in
place perception some aspect of
seeing a place okay
now all of this about the ppa i just
started in there because it's nice and
concrete and easy to think about but no
complex mental process happens in just
one brain region nothing is ever like
that
uh and likewise scene perception and
navigation is part of a much broader set
of regions so if you do a contrast scan
people looking at scenes versus objects
you'll see not just the ppa in here
again this is a folded up brain and this
is the mathematically unfolded version
so you can see the whole cortex dark
bits are the bits that were that used to
be inside a sulcus until it was
mathematically unfolded
so there's the ppa kind of hiding up in
that sulcus and when you unfold it you
see this nice big huge region okay
but you also see all these other regions
okay now there's a bunch of terminology
and i don't panic i don't think you
should memorize everything about each
region you should know that there's
multiple scene regions you should know
some of the kinds of ways you tease
apart the functions and some of the
functions that have been
tested and how they're tested but you
don't need to memorize every last detail
okay
because it's going to get a little hairy
okay so here's a second scene region
right there
called retrosplenial cortex or rsc
and uh actually russell epstein and i
saw that activation in the very very
first experiments we did in the 1990s
but we really didn't know what we were
doing back then and we knew that this is
right near the calcarine sulcus
remind me what happens in the calculus
sulcus what functional region lives in
the calcren sulcus
it's just a weird little fact but it's
kind of an important one
that we mentioned weeks ago
v1 primary visual cortex
that's where primary visual cortex lives
and remember primary visual cortex
has a map of retinotopic space with
next-door bits of primary visual cortex
responding to next-door bits of space
and in fact that map has the center of
gaze out here and the periphery out
there
so when russell and i first saw that
activation we had the same worry that
quilley mentioned a while back and that
is the scenes are sticking out there's
stuff everywhere the objects there isn't
that much sticking out and we thought oh
that's just peripheral retina topic
cortex but it's not it's right next to
there and it's a totally different thing
and it turns out to be extremely
interesting
you don't need to know all that it's
just silly little history
okay there's a third region up there
that's on the outer surface out there
um that used to be called tos and now is
now called opa i'm sorry about that you
don't need to remember this know that
there's not there are at least three
regions
um
what but t os opa is interesting because
there's a method we can apply
to it that we can't apply to the others
what would that method be
yeah tms it's right out on the surface
you just stick the coil there and go zap
so of course
we've done a lot of that okay you can't
get the coil into the ppa or rsc it's
too medial
all right
okay and there's another region that
we'll talk about more next time called
the hippocampus you saw the hippocampus
when ann graybill spent all that time
digging in the temporal lobe to find
that bumpy little dentite gyrus
approximately right in there
and so all of these and probably other
regions but these are the core elements
of the
of the scene selective regions that are
implicated in different aspects of
navigation
okay so when you have
multiple regions that seem to be part of
a system that's an opportunity
because now we have the possibility that
maybe we could figure out different
functions for different regions and then
maybe that would really tell us more
than just okay scenes and navigation end
of story it's kind of rude of entry
right it'll be nice if different aspects
of the navigation story
engage different parts of the system
okay
so really what we want to know is how
does each of these regions help us
navigate and see scenes
and i'm not going to answer that fully
we're still what the the field is still
trying to understand all of this but
i'll give you a few tantalizing little
snippets okay
so let's take retrosplenial cortex right
here
so um richard so this is first the
response of the ppa right there in
retrospective cortex which is just
behind it
this is just its mean response to a
bunch of different kinds of stimuli
showing the you that it likes landscapes
and cityscapes scenes more than a bunch
of other categories of objects and
that's true of both the ppa and rsc
okay no surprises here they're both
somewhat seen selective
okay
but then in a whole bunch of other
studies
summarized in this graph here
russell epstein and his colleagues
had subjects engage in different tasks
while they were looking at scenes in
some tasks they had to say where they
were
he's at u pen and he showed his subjects
pictures of the eupan campus and they
had to answer all kinds of questions
about
what part of campus they were where they
were in on campus and also about which
way they were facing given the view of
the campus they were looking at
okay
then he also showed people familiar
scenes and unfamiliar scenes much like
we did with our tough study
and he had object controls
and you can see the ppa doesn't care
about any of that doesn't care really if
they're familiar or unfamiliar doesn't
care what task you're doing on the scene
you're looking at a scene it's just
going
okay so we we didn't really tease of
heart functions there
but
rsc responds differently in these
conditions
it's more um
it's engaged in both the location task
and the orientation task
um it's um it doesn't oh it responds
substantially more
when you look at images of a familiar
place than an unfamiliar place so this
is the first time we've seen that in the
scene network and so now think about all
the things you can do when you're
looking at a picture of a scene and you
know that place
you have memories of having been there
you can think about you know what you
might do if you were there how you would
get from there to some place else all of
those things are possible things that
might be driving
rsc
another thing that might be driving rsc
is that if you're looking at a picture
of a familiar place
you orient yourself with respect to the
broader environment that that view is
part of
right so when i showed you that picture
of the front of stata you immediately
imagine oh like i'm out on vassar street
facing that way roughly
northwest i think
okay
if you look at a picture of a scene you
don't know that scene it doesn't tell
you anything about your broader heading
in the in the broader world okay so all
of those are things that
the rsc
its function seems to depend on knowing
that place
okay
perhaps the most telling case comes from
a patient who had damage in
retrosplenial cortex
and the description in the paper of this
says that this patient
could recognize buildings and the and
the landmarks and therefore understand
where he was
okay so lots is intact can recognize
scenes and know where he is
but the landmarks he recognized did not
provoke directional information about
any other places with respect to those
landmarks
okay
so this person can look at a picture and
say yeah i know that place you know
that's the front of my house
but then if you say you know in which
direction is you know a coffee shop two
blocks away
he doesn't know which way it is from
there
okay
so um this should sound familiar
this is my guess of the bit that my
friend bob
got messed up
yeah this is exactly his description he
could recognize places but it wouldn't
tell him how to get from there to
somewhere else
okay
and so the best current guess about
retrospinal cortex is it is involved in
you know anchoring where you are you
have this mental map of the world
and you have a scene and you're trying
to put them together given that i see
this
where am i on the map and which way am i
heading in that map
okay
again think about the problem you face
when you emerge from the subway in
manhattan right like you look around
where am i and which way am i heading
that's what you need retrospective
cortex for
okay
all right how about this tos thing i'll
give you there's lots of studies of it
i'll give you just one little offering
okay so
this is a
causal investigation because as we
discussed tos is out on the lateral
surface so we can zap it and so of
course we do
and so in this study
we were asking
whether tos is involved in perceiving
the structure of space around you
so we took scenes like this from cad
programs and we just varied them
slightly so for example the position of
this wall moves around
the aspect ratio the height of the
ceiling moves around and we make this
subtle morph space of different versions
of this image
okay
and then for control condition we do the
same with faces we morph between this
guy and that guy who make a whole
spectrum in between
and then in the task what we do is
here's one trial
one of the scenes or faces comes on
uh briefly and then shortly thereafter
you get a choice of two and you have to
say which of these matches that one
okay
and then what we do is we zap people
right after we present this stimulus
okay
and so the idea is this is as close as
we can get to a pretty pure perceptual
task how well can you see the shape of
that environment or the shape of that
face
okay you don't have to remember it for
more than a few hundred milliseconds so
it's really more of a perception task
than a memory task okay and what we
measure is we actually
um
muck with how different these two images
are in each trial and measure how far
apart they have to be in morph space for
you to be about 75 percent correct okay
that's a kind of
standard psychophysical measure the
details don't matter but our dependent
measure is how different did the stimuli
have to be for you to discriminate them
as a function of what do you get whether
you're getting zapped in tos or not
okay
and so here are the data
so let's take the case where you're
doing the scene task here
what this threshold is is again how
different the stimuli need to be for you
to discriminate them so the higher the
bar
the worse performance okay they have to
be really different or you can't tell
them apart
and so what you see is
when you zap
opa
that lateral scene selective region
discrimination
threshold goes up a bit that means you
get worse at the discrimination the
stimuli need to be more different
compared to zapping the top of your head
okay remember you always want to control
condition and there's no perfect control
condition because it feels differently
to be zapped in different places but
getting zapped up here is a
you know
better than nothing control
and then here's the occipital face area
that's the lateral face region we talked
about before when i showed you another
tms study basically whenever there's
anything lateral we zap it because we
can't
and see it's not affected here
zapping the occipital face area does not
mess up your ability to discriminate the
scenes
however
in the face task we see the opposite
pattern for the face task
zapping
the occipital place area doesn't do
anything compared to zapping the top of
your head but zapping the face area does
this is a double dissociation
okay if we just had
if we just had the scene task and be
like yeah maybe
who knows
maybe
maybe who knows why but you know it's
not very strong but when you have these
opposite things then we really have much
more
um strong evidence that these two
regions have different functions from
each other
okay everybody get that this is a double
dissociation in the same sense of when
you have one patient with damage in one
location and another patient with damage
in another location and they have
opposite patterns of deficit then we're
really kind of in business then we can
draw strong inferences
okay
all right so we just said all of that
okay so that's just a little snippet
these and other data suggest that that
region
um is strongly active when you look at
scenes uh and it seems to be involved in
something like perceiving you know
directly online perceiving the structure
of the space in front of you
okay
all right um so
um
yeah we already did retrosplenial cortex
and next time we'll talk about the
hippocampus in there and its role
in the whole navigation thing
now since i
have
ended early
a rare event i actually put together a
whole other piece of this lecture and i
thought no don't always have a part you
don't get to
but then it turns out
maybe we do get to it
um
okay we're gonna we're gonna go over
this more later but we're going to start
with this
business right here so anybody have
questions about the stuff so far
okay
so i've spent a lot of time talking
about multiple voxel pattern analysis
because it's the only method i've
mentioned so far that enables us to go
beyond the business of saying
how strongly do the neurons fire in this
region to the more interesting question
of what information is contained in this
region okay
but i also ended the last lecture with
this kind of depressive note
that you can't see much with mvpa
applied to face patches
even when we know there's information in
there with electrophysiology data
remember i showed you that monkey study
where they tried mvpa in the face
patches and monkeys and they couldn't
kind of read out a damn thing
and then they try mvpa on individual
neural responses of the same region and
they can read out all kinds of
information and that tells you the
information is there and we just can't
always see it with mvpa now today you've
seen cases where you can see stuff with
mvpa in the scene region so sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't
and when it doesn't work we're left in
this unsatisfying situation that we
don't know if the information isn't
there
or if the neurons are just so scrambled
together
that we just don't we can't see the um
see the different patterns
okay
so bottom line we need another method
mvpa is a whole lot better than nothing
but we want to be able to ask is there
information present in this region
even when we think the relevant neurons
are all spatially intermingled
okay so let me just do a little bit of
this and then we'll continue later okay
so goal we want to this is this new
method is called
event related functional mri adaptation
okay
and we use it when we want to know if
neural populations in a particular
region can discriminate between two
stimuli or two stimulus classes
so for example
do neurons in the ffa distinguish
between this image
and that image
okay so if we want to know that
we could measure the functional mri
response in the ffa and find this would
be an event related response similar
responses to the two
okay
and as i just mentioned
that wouldn't mean that there isn't
information
in the ffa that discriminates that it
just says they have the same mean
response everybody get that
okay
now
if we zoom in and think about what might
neurons be doing
it's still possible even with the same
mean response that neurons could be
organized like this with some of them
responding only to this image and some
of them responding only to that image
but it's also possible that all of the
neurons respond equally to both
and we kind of desperately need to know
i mean not in this case this is a toy
example obviously but we often when
we're trying to understand a region of
the brain we need to know which
situation we're in
okay
so
that neural population can discriminate
these two and that one can't
okay
how are we going to tell which is true
well we talked before about multiple
voxel pattern analysis but as i just
said it only works
when the neurons are spatially clustered
on the scale of voxels
okay so
imagine you have these situations here
this is getting more and more of a toy
example but just to give you the idea
suppose where those neural populations
land with respect to voxels is like this
so if each of these is a voxel in the
brain a little say two by two by three
millimeter chunk of brain that we're
getting an mri signal from
if you have the different neural
populations spatially segregated enough
that they mostly land in different
voxels
then mvpa might work here
is that intuitive do you guys all see
that then we get a different pattern in
these voxels
for looking at those two different
images
but even if we have
the situation here which is kind of
informationally the same if they're
spatially scrambled
so that they're in roughly equal
proportion in each voxel mvpa won't work
does that make sense
and so that's when we need this other
method called functional memory
adaptation
makes sense
okay i'm going to go one minute over
probably
okay so the point of functional mri
adaptation is it can work even when
there's no spatial clustering of the
relevant neural populations on the scale
of voxels so let me go through it
quickly and we'll come back to it later
so here's how it goes the basic idea is
any measure that's sensitive to the
sameness versus difference between two
stimuli
can reveal what that system takes to be
same or different
okay
so for example if a brain region
discriminates between two similar
stimuli like these
then
if we measure the functional mri
response in that region to same versus
different trials
okay so this would be a different trial
you present
trump and then the chimp back to back
that's one trial
compared to a same trial chimp and then
chimp
and of course we counter balance
everything so we also do chimp and then
trump in another different case and then
trump and then trump in another same
case right
if we find
that the neural response is higher when
the two stimuli are different than when
they're the same
then
we know that that region has neurons
that respond differentially to the two
okay so remember we started with a case
where the mean response is the same
to this image in this image if you just
measure them along
but now we want to know are
do we really have neurons that respond
differentially so we're using the fact
that neurons are like people and muscles
if you keep doing the same thing to them
they get bored
been there done that okay
so you present this back to back you get
a lower response than if you present
this and then this
okay that's called functional mri
adaptation it's like that waterfall mta
adaptation we talked about before but
just crammed into a fine time scale
okay and so then if you do that you can
ask what a region thinks is the same
okay
so then we could ask okay what about
these two images
does it think those are the same
and if we find a response like that what
have we learned so if these two respond
like that what have we learned
about a region that shows this is all
fake data obviously but if we saw that
what have we learned
and then i'll let you go
as soon as i get a nice answer to this
um so if it's the same between two
pictures of the same stimuli that means
that it's activated like it can
discriminate but if it were um
if the yellow line had the same degree
as the red you would just be reacting to
different pictures
i totally get that it's probably right
but totally get it
key point just because i don't want to
torture you guys and go way over but key
point is
it's
the same response is the lower response
we tell that with this case when we
actually give it a same one so same is
lower than different that's just how
this method works
then we're basically asking does that
count as the same to this brain region
and we're finding yes it does
that tells us that those neurons are
invariant to all kinds of things
viewpoint facial expression
you know when he last dyed his hair you
know who the hell knows all these other
things right
so we'll talk more about this but the
idea is now we have another method in
addition to mvpa that can start to tell
us what neurons are actually
discriminating okay sorry to go over
you